hey everybody at Santa Mac and welcome
to the third installment of our week's
best anime videos this is a series that
helps you guys catch up on any awesome
anime videos that you might have missed
in the past week all the links to the
videos that we mentioned are right there
in the description and if you want to
recommend a video for next week just
leave it in the comments we're gonna
start things off with the biggest and
best story for the entire anime
community on YouTube on Wednesday misty
connects yeah one of the biggest anime
youtubers announced that he and his wife
Jess are expecting a baby no this is
such awesome news guys it means that
another little anime fan is on the way
and you have to see this video misty
whose real name is Matteo or Matt got
really emotional in the video he talked
about some of the struggles than him and
his wife have been going through and
yeah he was really open in this video he
was really candid and I found it very
powerful i found it brave check it out
misty congratulations to you and your
family from us at anime uproar
felicitous young guys make sure you go
to that video and hit up misty on social
media and send them your best wishes and
yeah I misty you did well my friend you
did well this week the anime man
actually teamed up with a few other
youtubers to create a rap song as a
tribute to samurai champloo on the
second channel Joey talked about how
much you really love doing this and how
happy he was with the final product if
you're a fan of hip-hop music and of
samurai champloo definitely watch this
video and I have to say I'm impressed
the anime man proved that people from
Australia can actually rap which is in
itself a huge accomplishment you cook
uploaded a list this week of the top 20
actual anime that every anime fan needs
to watch and this is a hilarious
satirical list that pokes fun at some of
the common cliches and within the anime
community you will find lots of laughs
in this video and you will definitely
appreciate all the references to popular
topics memes and debates within the
anime community so definitely absolutely
watch this video on tuesday aki dearest
uploaded a samurai buyer unboxing video
and she actually cosplays this ramen ram
from our easy row in this one if you're
an Aussie fan definitely watch this
video if you're a cosplay fan definitely
watch this video and just in general
watch this video need i say more need i
say more
the sword art online movie is coming out
next year and this week soul animation
made a video talking about the second
trailer that's just been released for
sword art online the movie now I know a
lot of people love to hate on sword art
online but I personally really like the
premise so I do watch and I am gonna
watch the movie I realized there's a lot
of issues with character development but
I'm still gonna watch it now soul seems
really upset in this video about the
fact that the trailer appears to show
that kirito and asuna are not together
anymore so yeah we'll have to see about
that but either way man so it's gonna be
okay buddy it's gonna be okay no God
please no no no so if you're an sao fan
and you're looking forward to this movie
definitely check this video out it's
very useful and helpful geekdom 101
uploaded a whole bunch of videos this
week about dragon ball super he uploaded
a review of episode 61 he uploaded a lot
of info about future trunks so if you're
looking for some good dragon ball super
analysis definitely check out his videos
just beware of spoilers on Saturday Bob
samurai uploaded a video about the top
10 anime available on Netflix and he
actually talked about the top 10 best
rated anime on netflix and he also gave
some of his own thoughts about other
animated should have been on that list
but or not now I found this video very
useful because I know that there's some
really good anime on netflix like wooden
log on Death Note steins gate but there
also some enemy I've never heard of and
some of them like knights of cydonia I
watched and I really liked but then
others like audien I started watching
and I wasn't that impressed I mean it's
still watchable but it's okay so yeah I
found this video really useful if you
watch anime on netflix and you're
looking for something to watch check out
the video now the last video of this
week is an MV uploaded by anime unity
and they actually featured an amv that
was made by a whole bunch of different
people with each person making only
about 15 seconds of the actual video I
thought this was a really interesting
concept it featured a bunch of different
anime and I think it turned out actually
really well so definitely check it out
so yeah guys that's all for this week if
you like these videos please be sure to
LIKE and subscribe and until next time
see a space cowboys